[Music]
I think he's doing a great job it's
better than the leadership we had prior
I think his leadership has been weak but
I think people are kind of bought into
it in the sense of we've had it for so
long to see if we can keep going we
survived but at the same time I do feel
like he's a little you know too old
America is a nation that can be defined
in single word I was going to foot him
foot most persons are getting old but uh
I kind of seen them more as a puppet
like he just kind of signs and goes with
the flow with things I get across his
desk probably care about foreign policy
and there I feel he's really a good job
domestically you know be yogre I don't
think I'm educated enough to give
opinion on good or bad I think there's
some good qualities and some bad
qualities just like with any candidate I
would just like a newer candidate to
vote for um in 2024 public perception
and particular
with a lot of the kind of advertising
focusing on his age and moments where he
looks on camera to be a daughtering old
man this is a weakness but it's a
marketing weakness but his actual record
is very impressive I don't think most
people are excited about Biden but I I
think they are less enthusiastic about
change with anyone else full disclosure
I did vote for him in 2020 I think it
was appropriate at the time but um I
would not be excited about voting for
him again and I don't know that I would
there is no other strong alternative
candidate at the moment and I think
what's going to happen as we get closer
to the uh election is that his record is
going to be gradually uh continuing to
improve